we don't do who he'd love he wouldn't  exist I'm good it's like nothing really  matters to him right now  including me you gotta think real hard  about this do you have people that need  you know I'm taking the fight  Victor Drago son of Ivan Drago who  infamously killed Apollo Creed appeared  today to issue a challenge to Adonis  Creed don't do this  I ain't got a choice let's assume that  your father said you died right here in  my hands  that kid was raised in Haiti  dangerous he broke things to me that  ain't never been fixed ain't worth it is  that just us anymore of day I want to  rewrite history if you want to fight  this man that's your business but don't  pretend this is about your father  this is all about  it was right without an  the tribulation  [Music]  this won't be the end to me  are you  because we're a team  [Music]  now you know what you're fighting for  Wow after brown you learn more about  yourself when I stepped in Henry it  wasn't all about me  [Music]